since we can't travel in person we
created share your world
a show where fellow travel lovers and i
share experiences from our cultural
backgrounds
in this episode we're saving room for
desserts
some save it for the end of the meal and
others skip straight to it
no matter how you enjoy them desserts
are a sweet form of comfort food served
around the world
my favorite armenian dessert is gata
it's like a sweet round
pastry and it's just really good when
you have it with like tea
or in the morning as breakfast or just a
pastry on its own
also with gata sometimes the bakers put
a little coin
in there and whoever gets like the slice
with the coin is set to have
good luck so i remember as a kid i would
always like eat so much just
so i can get the coin and i can get the
good luck if you go
to like villages like gagne and gerard
those women
over there make it a certain way and
they usually put like armenian letters
over it
um or they write gerard which is the
place that they are from
so one of my favorite cambodian desserts
is sticky rice with mango and coconut
milk
i actually went to cambodia and my uncle
owns a restaurant
where he actually made the dessert for
me so the mango is not your typical
mango
it's this long yellow mango as opposed
to the green and red one
and it's more like overly shaped than
the round circle
when you eat foods that have emotional
connections to it i think it does taste
better
so every time i eat it now again i
i remember of my time in cambodia
so whenever i visit korea the first
thing i do
is i go get this dessert called popping
zoo it's a shaved ice it's about
die high they put condensed milk they
put fruit pieces they put mochi rice
cakes red bean and you can get like
matcha flavor vanilla hazelnut
it's so refreshing and much much lighter
than ice cream
so the last time i went to visit my
parents i stayed at the jw marriott
hotel in seoul
and it's in this neighborhood called
myeongdong and they just have
all these street vendors late at night
and like a ton of food options and
there's a ton of shopping in the area
so i will drag my parents out at like 11
midnight
and we will go stop by all the little
street vendors and then
for like a dessert drink there's this
sweet rice milk
it's not thick at all so it's like the
consistency of lemonade
and it's slightly sweet and it's
refreshing and has little pieces of rice
in it so then you kind of like at the
end you kind of like swirl it so you can
get all the rice chunks even though i
like to buy the sweet rice drink i
always want my mom to make a whole batch
as well
so i'll use my marriott bomboy boundless
card to earn points by buying all the
ingredients
so it's so beneficial because i'm like
spending it on the car but also earning
points so i just feel like it all works
out great
having this card i will travel anywhere
just to try all the best desserts
the best snacks the best meals like i'm
all about it you know to me
food is also art i'm with you on that
plus one on the foodie i will travel for
food as well
yep honestly when i was younger my
biggest dream was working in a swiss
bakery
because i just love every bit of pastry
that we have back home
and when you go to swiss bakery the way
they present it
it's just absolutely beautiful two of my
favorite pastries which
i mean you have it here in america as
well it's carrot cake and a black forest
cake
we can buy it here in america but it's
just obviously not the same recipe
it's different back home so the
chocolate that's on top of the black
forest cake in switzerland
it's just this very thinly sliced
chocolate
and inside the black forest cake there's
dark cherries and i think here in
america a lot of times it's the bright
red cherries
they're just softer and they have a much
richer taste to it the carrot cake back
home is really just
uh the cake base with carrots in it and
then the top
is uh like a sugary glaze uh that you
make yourself you can add some lemon to
it for flavor
and then we actually have little um
carrot shaped marzipans
that we like decorate it with i
literally can't get enough of it so
whenever i go to switzerland
you bet i'm gonna eat those things
[Laughter]
yeah like with switzerland you know
you're gonna try chocolate but
like no one told me i should try the
carrot cake too
yeah cause it's i said like because we
like in america you know carrot cakes
it's not something
that you would necessarily try in a
different country because it's not
specific to switzerland
it's just the way that we make it is
different we're surrounded by a bunch of
countries it is germany just for
instance italy
it's a very small country but very very
international
so we do like to borrow ideas and
recipes
from our surrounding countries i am
so hungry after our conversation i
definitely learned a lot and i can't
wait to try
everything that we talked about if you
got a sweet tooth from watching this
video
we hope you're inspired to start
planning your next dessert-filled
[Music]
adventure
[Music]
you